She's having the time of her life while lowering
her A1C, but the actress from the Jardiance
commercial has a much bigger story to tell
about her life in showbiz.
One of the most ubiquitous commercials on
TV right now is for the prescription drug Jardiance.
It's designed to help people with type 2 diabetes
keep their blood sugar levels under control,
but you probably know it better for its elaborate
song-and-dance routine with an actress enthusiastically
extolling its virtues.
The commercial has generated quite a bit of
buzz, especially among viewers who are curious
about who exactly its star performer is.
Her name is Deanna Colón, and she's no stranger
to show business.
And this definitely isn't her first time on
TV, as she was a contestant on America's Got
Talent back in 2013.
During her run on the competition show, Colón
blew the judges away when she auditioned with
a rendition of "And I Am Telling You I'm Not
Going" from the musical Dreamgirls.
She ultimately made it to the quarter-semifinals
before being eliminated.
But that was just the beginning of her career.
The same year that she appeared on AGT, she
also booked an extensive ad campaign for Big Lots.
On top of all that, she's assembled numerous
soundtrack and music department credits on
TV shows and films.
"Since I was like seven or eight, I used to
be in my basement, singing along with Whitney
Houston and Mariah Carey records."
Deanna Colón actually got her start in showbiz
under the name Deanna DellaCioppa, which is
what she went by during her time on America's
Got Talent.
She's been a prolific performer in commercials
for years, with many of them incorporating
music, as that is her specialty.
And a look at her IMDb reveals many additional
credits behind the camera, as she's contributed
music to such shows as Sex and the City, The
Hills, and The League, just to name a few.
Outside of commercials, Colón's acting credits
are much less numerous, with just one listed
on IMDb, as she appeared on a 2021 episode
of the TBS anthology comedy series Miracle Workers.
With all the attention that her Jardiance
commercial has been getting, it's certainly
possible that we'll be seeing more of Colón
on our screens in the future.
And if her music work continues along at the
same pace, we could very well hear her, or
music composed by her, without even realizing
it.
Based on this trajectory, it seems like Colon's
clout in the entertainment industry is only growing.
On her Instagram, she recently confirmed that
she's the voice behind the song in one of
Instacart's most popular ads.
While she can't be seen in the commercial,
which has over 1 million views on YouTube,
we can hear her distinctive voice bring the
ad to life.
We have a feeling that she'll eventually be
fondly remembered for more than just Jardiance.
In addition to working on some of the TV world's
most popular shows and commercials, Colón
also works as a vocal coach.
And she boasts quite the prestigious background,
as she graduated from the iconic Berklee College of Music.
She originally emerged from humble beginnings,
but her time at Berklee afforded her some
significant opportunities.
As she revealed in a 2020 interview with VoyageLA,
during her time at Berklee, she won her first
national singing jingles and also sang for
iconic musicians like Diana Ross and Patti LaBelle.
Colón had to break some barriers to become
successful, and now she's at a point in her
career where she can say that she's quite
proud of herself.
As she declared to VoyageLA,
"I truly feel there is nothing I can not do."
Colón's story is the kind that shows just
what you can accomplish with enough hard work.
In addition to all of her acting and singing
work, she's also a popular creator on social
media, as she boasts nearly 300,000 followers
on TikTok.